hi my name is Joe Ellis sandrini and
with my colleague McHale we are going to
present the latest addition in the field
of OCR and fish analysis using our new
neural network capabilities
my name is Micah and Julia we we worked
both an image and signal processing team
and we will be presenting to you what's
new in the OCR and facial recognition
aspects which are integrated and not yet
in into the Wolfram language so just one
brief point we are doing the talk
together so maybe let's get all the
questions at the end because we don't
have much time yep all right so I will
be talking about the optical character
recognition capabilities in the Wolfram
language and the integration with neural
networks to do some cool stuff so just
to give you some background - so we had
text recognized since version 8 it has
been changed a bit since that time and
the latest update was in 11.2 so what we
added is basically now you have a way to
specify the level and the property you
want to extract so we'll take a look
what they are right now so let's let's
first see what what the properties are
so one may specify now if it what to
recognize basically to recognize the
text or to get the bounding boxes or to
get the strength of of the recognition
so say in case of this image here so I
see that the recognition is the strength
of the recognition is pretty high and
we'll we'll see this particular example
in more details later on and there is
also a level specification which can be
specified to recognize the whole block
the world lion character and so on so
basically this is in case of this image
we just recognize the text word by word
and this is pretty cool all in all you
could come up with
nice-looking data sets which will
describe your image instance of what
text is located where and you could even
extract the images of the text
recognized per the level of the level
that you specified
and there are also some new options in
there one of them is something which is
called recognition prior so what
recognition prior is is it's something
that too helped the text recognizer to
to understand what what it's going to
work with so let's take a look at this
example so this looks like an M yeah
does look better or a bit more more
better now
okay
right okay okay so in case of this this
image it's it's like from the first you
know it seems to be a letter M but
actually if we specify that we are
interested to see what what is it in a
sense of being a character we will see
that this is indeed M but if we do not
specify what it is it will recognize it
basically symbol by symbol we can see
that these are actually not connected
between each other and this is
recognized as a Roman letter M so kind
of another another interesting new
option is something called masking which
basically takes a region or regions in a
form of image or or actually actual
rectangles to help text recognizer to
figure out where approximately the text
is so in case of this image I specify
that there is this mask where the white
part is responsible for the region that
there is a text in there and to
recognize I see that it yes indeed this
is the stuff and your mind is the text
that is located in that part so again
the kind of partial access to what we
want to recognize last but not least
there is new thing in in specifying
languages so pretty much it was like you
could specify what language that a the
text is and to try to recognize but
there was actually a problem because you
could have different languages with
different sets of alphabets where the
characters are different now you could
specify different languages at the same
time to specify what languages are
present in the image and you can see
that in this case we have like German we
have Russian and we have Spanish or
could be Italian and we did the
alphabets are different like this
aesthetic is not present in our
different alphabets and as a soul so so
we can see that the recognition is
taking the right language or text unit
now like to to to to give you an idea
what all these can be useful I'll be
presenting some applications some of
them to applications to to show how can
these be actually used
in real examples so say we have an image
like this which is a graphic and we have
some letters on it which each of them is
assigned to a point now if we try to do
a text recognize some of these you'll
see that there is nothing recognized
actually but what we can do we can use
the thing with with maths we can
basically try to specify a mask to help
the text recognizer to locate where the
text is on the image and now and that's
that's basically it and we know that per
segment in the mask we we are interested
in in characters so recommend we need to
specify character as a recognition prior
value so let's try to do so we have
something let's let's let's see how what
it actually is
so what we got is like we got that the
texts are located in these red bounding
boxes and if we hover with we will see
the actual recognition which is pretty
accurate for this example and the
strength of the recognition so this is a
kind of a toy example how the masks and
the recognition prior option can be
useful the next thing I would like to
talk about is as I said we will be
talking about the optical character
recognition as well as the integration
of neural networks into them so say we
have an image like this and the text
recognized is not initially trained to
to work on natural images so again if I
try to recognize text from these images
like this London and maverick here we
will see that there is nothing happening
over there but I have a I've imported a
neural network just a random one from
from from just surfing and it's like
pretty straightforward and applying it
on the image I now try to figure out
what are the where the text is located
on the image this is kind of an
automation of specifying the masking
which which does it for you so we now
know that the text is located somewhere
in here for the first image and here for
the second image now we can take a look
and see that indeed when we specify the
located the location of the text the
recognition is significantly improved
and we get the exact the bounding
highlight
thinking the exact text that was written
on the image another cool thing that we
could do is to have an image like this
which is kind of a vocabulary screenshot
from a from an Internet and now let's
let's try to convert this to to an
actual Wolfram language representable
table vocabulary so what we do is again
we need our network to try to extract
the approximate position of the text on
this image and well what it does is that
actually just just finds the text and
and gives us a bounding box so that's
pretty much all we need for for this
type of examples and we see that the the
text detection went like pretty accurate
first for some cases is not that
accurate but I mean this is something
that was never trained by us for for a
specific purpose this is just a random
Network okay now what we need to do is
we need to basically differentiate the
left column from the right column to
figure out what which word corresponds
to the other word which is basically the
translation of the letter and that's
that's pretty again pretty
straightforward to do so basically we
know that the left column now is Russian
and the right column is English and what
we can do now is just do the recognition
stuff and recreate the Wolfram language
table vocabulary which is the almost
accurate representation of the previous
one it's not like so you can see that
restaurant here is not super accurately
detected but again there is way way way
there ways to to improve these things
another thing that may interest some of
you is that when you have a plot like
this we can actually try to recreate the
plot count contents and the plot
skeleton into into the Wolfram language
so what we do we again just need to
extract the positions where the text is
located on the image and this actually
should be accurate enough not to
misinterpret the plot curves as letters
or as possible text so we see in this
example this is kind of accurate enough
for us
to do things now what we need to do is
basically as an example as we did in
example with vocabulary we need to
basically differentiate what are the
axes and without the labels and put
everything in the correspondence so this
is a game super straightforward to do
we'll see that the verticals are these
the horizontals are these and labels are
separated so we now have all the all the
bounding boxes that that are interesting
to us to be able to recreate the
graphics and we just do extract the
ranges for the the range for the axis
which is done using the text recognized
stuff and also the labels which is done
using the same thing now we what we need
to do is basically we need to figure out
what are the what are the graphic points
the actual points of the graphic on the
image we have and try to reproduce it on
the fold and we can see that this is
pretty much accurate reproduction of the
plot that we had in image so basically
thanks recognize was responsible to was
responsible to create the skeleton at a
classical image processing techniques
were responsible to recreate the actual
graphics on this plot last but not least
probably the most fun example we could
do something like having a tabular
tabular notation for for music and make
war from language to play them actually
so again what we do we we need now to we
need to gain to figure out where the
text is located but in this case we will
not be using the neural networks that
will reproduce using the classical image
image processing approaches and we see
that this image we just okay now we have
the old all the bounding boxes where the
tabulations are located on the image now
what we need to do we need basically to
to recognize them to see what exactly is
written where and to to make it in a
form so that we can fit it to our sound
object and to just to show you how it
looks
okay so this is this is something that
we are going to feed to to the sound
this is not something meaningful to look
at but to have an idea what's what's
what's gonna happen there and now yeah
and now we can just feed this to to a
sound object and to have actual Led
Zeppelin playing to play like 47 seconds
but the main idea behind is that when
you have a tabular note it's pretty
straightforward and note that seriously
hard problem to to make to make it play
in Wolfram language I guess that's it on
my side and I like just julia to
continue with the facial stuff
in our building functionalities so this
stuff is not even in any builds right
now I think most of it at least
and so again like I'm starting from
something but we used to have and let's
see how we can expand on that so for
example II you probably may be familiar
with fine phases
it's our favorite actor right now he's
using like classical image processing to
find faces and so there's like much room
of like not just improvement but also
like extra functionality that you can
inject into functions like this so like
this is a kind of standard like let's
find well bounding box for faces are in
the image but why why we this is
experimental design so don't don't do
for it in it like in any future release
yet it's not even approved but why in
principle we we cannot do something like
this I mean it's perfectly says it's
sensible like we just want to face is
related to a woman in the picture so I
just I just inject some like in your
network knowledge into fine faces and
this allows me to get exactly the the
answer I want and this is basically via
technology that's behind our face demoed
downstairs and Oh like I can expand this
arbitrary there's more properly the more
necklace I have the more property I can
deal with the the more richer the
previous place is like for example give
me just faces for people under the age
of 20 and I just got the baby so as I
was saying like the idea is is to use
like both internal stuff and like new
network and new classifiers and like
merge it all together some of this you
can do already for example I think is a
TN you're here no okay is we seen lemon
- I think this facial thing is the
facial gender is in 11 - stuff okay so
this you can do already with the latest
build so you can ask for example this is
calling in your network from within and
it's telling me okay this man is
actually a man and like these things are
like building in a smart way into the
language so you can you can see that the
support like sound art reading like this
is kind of sound evaluation this is like
multi tried evaluation is faster and
they have this nice operator forms and
people always ask me like why do you
want to use the parental forms
we have summer functions is because then
you can like merge them very easily in
other functions for example I love this
group by function it allows you like
kind of MapReduce so let's say I want
now to do is just sort them by and group
them by gender I just provide the
operator and boom is done
so like this like an automatic data set
creation with like injecting neural
network of abilities into the language
mmm so just talking a bit about future
plans like I'm working out to something
like this and this is not the final form
again the idea is to have kind of a hub
for like different features this will
eventually grow the more I play with
this and right now we have a kind of
standard stuff you can get like age you
can agendas certain landmarks like
without the eyes what knows is you can
get like descriptors and we plan to be
like rich in this and I'm gonna show you
in later examples like what you can do
this kind of stuff for example like this
descriptor here like I don't know who's
familiar with like feet restriction like
you have an object in this case a face
and you want to do computation on that
but this is an image I mean for us is
very easy for a computer not as much
like you you want it to work on numbers
possibly meaningful numbers and not
always using the pixel of images is the
best for this so what you what you want
to do we have already feature a struct
function and we are richer the idea is
like you want to use like specialized
features that contain semantic
information of the object you are
working with so in this case I I scrape
the internet for some it is just a
Google web search for a precedent face
like these two keywords and this is
meeting like some like some other symbol
some like weird stuff but I mean for the
most part there are faces of presidents
if I use feet of space plot this is
using the standard image feature
structure which is basically is trying
to guess the appropriate manifold like
to represent a natural image but not
just the face like any image so this is
the rich structure maybe isn't too rich
for this problem so we see that like
some like
all the grayscale images are together
this black and white is here like there
are like people kind of background maybe
on one side like there already some
semantic in here but it's not like
specific face semantic so now I'm
calling feet of space plot again but
using a game this is an operator so is
like getting this descriptor from like
my fashion my custom facial feeder
function and you see but now for example
like all the faces of Obama are to
cluster together in the same area of a
feature space plot because I mean this
this representation is way better and
capturing face information so it knows
about like oh I mean one person looks
here or there is the same person it's
not different image it has a concept
like it had been trained on like
multiple image to the same person while
maybe stand a classifier as just a bunch
of people a bunch of mushrooms a bunch
of different things but it's not like
very learned in doing something like
this
and once you have this you can but by
the way this is the color I used to
scrape images if you want to do it
yourself once you have this you can
create your own custom classifiers for
example like let's say I want to like
here I will skip a bunch of Obama faces
and like random present faces and then
activity a problem I want to like learn
what an Obama face look like and and and
differentiate that from external faces
so here we don't have much time so I use
a super simple approach i I just reduce
this to two dimension to make make it
like nicely I represent a ball and you
see the red dots are my data set of
Obama faces and and they're like
thumbnails are the faces in the world
and you already see that like if you are
able to to create a distribution of the
of the red dots you can then easily use
a distribution to extract the amount of
faces from the while working in the same
space so I do exactly that
I didn't normalize a bit this and I I
create like this is a this is standard
normal distribution the like two three
four five Sigma lines and then I use
this to to filter the faces I compute
like the distance on my data set and you
get like this is a sigma parameter and
i'm going here from my point to sigma 2
3 sigma see if it's like 3 sigma is like
bunch of nice group Obama faces I know
qualities this tubular example but you
can train this on like whatever thing
you want just to show like very quickly
another another like set of features
that you can in you may want to play
with we have support confession
landmarks so here I'm using particularly
the slightly richer network that would I
had in the container function before
this is defining like a something like
about how many like 20 so points for
each face and when I had this I can like
bid all kind of our algorithm that are
like sensitive to they put position of
like specific facial features like I
want to from like building a snapshot
filter to like doing
I don't know face of confiscation if you
have to under my pictures like more
serious thing and just to show very
quickly an example of what you can do I
can use the neural network to get the
feature in this case the points and then
I can use standard image processing to
define as plan interpolation between two
functions so I can do like this is like
very crude face molding and again with
like stander image precision technique I
can merge like this nice girl and make
it like sort of as one direction or the
other direction which is this is pretty
gross and then in the demo here I put
some like you may see that some these
are pretty crude I'm just like blurring
a bit the mask but you can use like some
multi-resolution branding and create
pyramids and they all kind of like star
image process technique so I can leave
these two fields are not really not
talking to each other like as much we
can do this much we will do and and I
hope that is much that you will be able
to do with the instruments that we
provide thank you
some any question for me Oh Miko come
here
but you probably could get more or less
convenient results with what we have
right now
yeah you
I think if you if you for your
particular problem you you better use
classifier I guess I mean like take
texts recognize is as to is currently
not intended to recognize any
handwriting's the the its intended to
recognize any scans or printed documents
and for the hand and and recognition
especially if you have like like
handwriting from one person you you
probably would have to do additional
training to to kind of help Tech's
recognize to handle it I mean this kind
of stuff is planned to be in not today
not tomorrow but but it it we know about
that and it's in our plans well Matt is
absolutely different story I mean like
for for the example I showed with
graphics it's again like semi math
because you have some points and you
have like letters assigned to them but
especially doing some math OCR is again
not something text recognized is
intended to do
it's not designed for that I mean but
again this is again something that is
working problems currently right now we
are just at the beginning of our like
image to text capability and I mean it's
a direction we want to work for what you
but yeah it's very very at the
improvement state right now so I
wouldn't advise you to use this to do
your math OCR yet
sure the our our plan is basically to
expose every network we use and some of
them like well our our framework is
maturing as well like the we push we
want to use more networks so like we
push for improvements of a framework and
the new framework allows or to try new
stuff so like it's kind of a win-win
thing between the framework and ours but
I mean the the standard plan is to add
the you've seen that we have this net
model object and we want to expose there
basically everything so you will be able
to get the Train Network the untrained
network and use pieces what I do
whatever you want and there's also much
improved I mean the framework has been
evolving and in the 11:3 prototype
there's much improvement in like a
network like knitting like cutting
merging like is is getting easier and
easier so hopefully that will address
your needs I don't know if we can take
any more questions maybe one maybe zero
okay thank you
[Applause]